Transcriber: keioko shinegu
المدقّق: Mujtaba Abdelwhab
مرحبا انحن كبشر نحب رؤية أنفسنا في أحلى
صورة
فنسعي للظهور بالشكل الذي يريحنا
ولا يتسبب لنا بأحاديث،
وعلى هذه السيرة قصة الوزن الزائد بيتضايق
كثيرمنا،
وقتها نلجأ للرياضة برامج الدايت والرجيم
اللي مايخصصها كلها
ولما قررت اصل للوزن الذي
أنا عليه اليوم عملت بعض الفحوصات
فحص جيش
وزن، طول، دم، أسنان.
لكن لم أكن أرغب بدخول الجيش
لكن وزني كان يجب أن يخس.
ليس لأن فلان كان يحكي لي يا سمينة، ولا
لأن فلانة كانت تحكي لي يأم خدود.
بس كان عندي صاحب يعز علي وكانت ثقيل دمي
شوية،
ولذلك من أجله فقدت اثنا عشر كيلو من وزني
الموضوع بيبدأ من ان يقلق عليك أحدهم، أحد
مركز معك كثير ويعرف كل تفصيل لك،
أعني، شخص ملازم لك في حياتك.
في قصتي،
كانت أمي هي ذلك الشخص.
مركزة معي في كل تفاصيلي، وحاسباها بالملى
لما اليوم شربت ثلاث لتر ماء، لما اليوم
صحيت أربع مرات في الليل وفي الأربع مرات
كانت تفوت الحمام، لما اليوم تعبت بس أكلت
كذا وكذا وكذا ، لما لما لما وعلي
هذا الموال لحد ما خلصت توجيهي.
قرر والدي يعمل لي فحوصات.
هي الخاصة بالجيش .
لكن هذه المرة تَشخصت للمرة الأولى بمرض
السكري النوع الثاني، ومن هنا،
بدات حياتي تتغير كلياً.
اثنان وعشرون تموز ألفين سبعة عشر
لحظة سماعي لتأكيد الدكتور بأني فعلا سكرية.
رد فعلي كان هززت رأسي وتخيلت
كابوس كبير طرأ في حياتهي.
أشفقت على نفسي، كاني أمهد لرد فعل الناس
عندما يعرفون هذا الشئ عني.
فوراً قررت أن لا أحد سيعرف .
بدات بأقراص(ميتفورمين) بمعدل بسيط.
وبعد كم فترة بدأت مرحلتي الجامعية
تخصص آداب لغة إنجليزية،
لكن لم أكن مركزة على التخصص
قدر ما كنت أريد أن أخفي موضوع إني سكرية،
مثلا يعني لما نكون جالسين أنا وصاحباتي
نشرب قهوة أخجل أن أرفض قطعة شوكولاتة
مع القهوة، لما كنت أتعب في الجامعة
ما أعطي لنفسي فرصة اتصرف بضعفي،
بالعكس كنت أجبر نفسي لأقف مثل الصقر
ولاإني اعطي فرصة لأحد ليشكك في.
هذا مرة من المرات كنت أنا وزميلتي
في مطعم ورفضت نوع من الأكل عادي.
لكن عندما سمعت هذا الكلام حكت لي جملها
هزتني من فوق لتحت، بنظرة إستهزاء حكت لي
أأنت سكرية؟
كيف عرفت؟ من أخبرها؟.
أرأتني وانا أشرب الدواء؟ ورحت أنفي الموضوع
عن نفسي بشكل قطعي
كأني بحاول أثبت التهمة علي .
مواقف شك وإحراج تلاحق بعضها، لا هذه
ليست حياتي
بصحى على غبش في عيوني.
لازم ألتزم مواعيد الدواء.
بتصرف برا البيت عادي وبس أروح أتحول لزومبي
سكري عالي سكري واطي
الحقوني بقطعة شوكلاتة
ما حديحكي معي دايخة مثل كل يوم
بعد فترة قررت أغير الدكتور في خمسة يوليو
ألفين وثمانية عشر.
من هنا كانت عنوان المرحلة علاج تغيلي
الدكتور اعتبرني بلاعة حبوب، حبة، أثنين
ثلاثة، أربعة، خمسة، ستة،
سبعة سبع حبوب دمروني.
اللي عرفته بعدين إن سبع حبوب لمريض
السكري من النوع الثانى
مصيبة
في تلك الفترة صار معي علاقة كُره مع المرض.
صار صحتي أسوأ
معدل سكري ما ينزل عن مئتين.
تزوج أخي في هذه السنة أخي الكبير (محمد)
طبعا أنا كنت أخت العريس وكان لازم أضع كل
طاقتي لأظهر للمعازيم بالشكل المناسب.
ما أكشف سري
بعد إنتهاء تلك الليلة أصابني حالة انهيار.
وارتميت في البيت، ولا كأنني (لما)
التي كانت في الفرح.
وبعد ذلك اليوم كان يجب اخفاء الموضوع في
البيت مثلما أنا مخفيتة خارج البيت
تأزت نفسيا دخلت فترة إكتئاب شديد، وبنفس
الفترة خيرناي الدكتور ما بين شغلتين
أكمل العلاج بالحبوب،
كان صريح معي، ستتعبك بعدين يا
(لمى) أو إبدأي بالإنسولين.
الذي سأسمح لكِ فيها أن تاكلي كل شئ
لكن إبدأي بالانسولين .
هنا كانت التوعية التغفيلية عن المرض.
دكتور يتعامل مع مريض غير واعي على مرضه لم
يتطرق ليوضح أي معلومة عن المرض أو حتى
كيف تتعايش معه.
بكيت بكاء هيستيري ما كنت متخيله أني ممكن
أبدأ أنسولين بهذا العمر المبكر،
فقررت أكمل العلاج بالحبوب.
وبعد سنة ونصف من العلاج، لقيت صحتي تتراجع
بشكل مخيف،
فقررت وقف المراجعات.
حد بيقدر يكون صديق لعدوه؟
فكرة غريبة شوي، صح؟
بس بيقولك لتعرف تتعامل
مع عدوك تعلم لغته.
وأنا قررت أتعلم لغة المرض
في ألفين وتسعة عشر.
دخلت مرحلة وعي سكري ، بدات أتعرف على
المرض مع أبوي ونصائحه عن طريق النت.
شو يعني سكري؟
ما هو الفرق بين النوع الأول والنوع الثاني؟
لماذا الإنسولين؟ ماذا حصل لبنكرياسي؟
صار في علاقة تعايش مع المرض.
لقيت ومضة ارادة تلمع في سماء الفترة
بأن أكسب السكري كصديق بدل ان يضل عدو.
في أربعة عشر نوفمبر ألفين وتسعة عشر احتفلت
للمرة الأولى باليوم العالمي للسكري
وبيدي باللون أزرق.
لكن كل شئ في الخفى كان.
عن طريق طالب طب متعايش مع السكري النوع
الأول،
تعرفت على الدكتور جميل البهنساوي.
ومن هنا بدأت حياة السكرية الوردية الغليظة
شوية تتضح معالمها
عشرين عشرين ، قررت
أواجه خوفي، أتخلص من كابوس الإنسولين
بمواجة الإنسولين نفسه.
دكتور جميل من أعظم الأشخاص الذين مروا علي،
تعامل مع الجانب النفسي مثله مثل العلاج
الصحي، هيأني نفسيا جعلني على بينة من مرضي
وضح الأمور من نقطة الصفر.
في ستة عشر يونيو أخذت أول إبرة أنسولين،
وبدات نظام غذائي صارم،
ولما أحكي صارم
يعني مافي سكريات
ما في معظم النشويات مافي خبز أسمر،
ماقي خبز أبيض، ما في رز.
صعوبات كثيرة بهذا الطريق.
كيف أوفر بديل؟ كيف أمنع نفسي قدام كثير
أشياء،
وكيف أقنع الناس؟ أنه عندي نظام معين
فقررت أمشي تحت كذبة الدايت
الطريق بدأ يسهل،
وبدأ معدل سكري يرجع لوضعه الطبيعي.
مع كل خطوة كان السكري يعطيني
درس في الحياة، ومن أجملها.
إن المنع عطاء وذكرني بنعمة كثير مهمة
تعني لي الكثير
جيشي العظيم أهلي.
في واحد يونيو،
كانت أمي في المستشفى.
واتشخصت بكانسر غدد ليمفاوية
الخبر نزل كالصاعقة علينا.
لكن ماقلنا غير الحمد لله
أيام صعبة ودعنا أمي خلالها مرتين.
وبعد ما تحسنت صحتي وقربت من هدفي
كل شيء بدأ يتراجع.
بتلك الفترة قابلت الدكتور جميل وأخبرني
جملة أخذت منها شعار لحياتي كلها.
حكى لي (The sky is my edge)
السماء حدي،
صرت أكلم (لمى) كل يوم، أستثير طاقتها
لتقوي وتعافر في طريقها
لتوصل للسماء
ولأبعد من السماء.
رغبة في الانتصار كانت أكبر من كهوف ضعفه
ن
لهذا في اثنين مايو الفين واحد وعشرين،
وجدت رسالة من دكتور جميل يخبرني فيها
أنه مبسوط من قِِراءات معدل السكر.
إن الوضع بيتحسن واني أوقف
إبر الأنسولين نهائيا.
طعم البكاء والسجود بعمره ما
كان أحلى من ذلك اليوم.
إنتصرت في معركتي.
بس كان السر ثقيل علي قلبي
وتهربي من حقيقة
أني سكرية يزعجني
ولهذا قررت أن أكشف سري.
أعترف للكل أني سكرية فخورة بنفسي
أكسر حاجز خوف الرفض، إذ فرض احترام رغباتي
واتخلص من كذبة الدايت.
وبعد فترة قصيرة من وقف الانسولين، وقفت
آخر حبة ميتفورمين والفحص اليومي للسكر
الذي أخذ معي أكثر من ألف وخمسمائة
نخزة أصبع خلال السنة
آخر خطوة بعملها بهذا المشوار أني تخلصت
من كل الأدوية المتعلقة بالمرض.
هنا حسيت بنشوه الانتصار اللي استنتها كثير.
ومن فضل ربنا كرمه،
وبعد آخر جرعة كيماوي لامي العظيمة.
في ثمانية وعشرين يوليو تلقينا خبر أن
جسمها خال من كل الأورام بفضل الله.
السكري ما كان له أثر على حياتي الصحية وبس،
كان له أثر على قراراتي الحياتية،
الشخصية، الجامعية،
التي تحولت من خوف لشجاعة،
من تردد لمواجهة،
في احد عشر من يوليو، تخرجت من
جامعة الأقصى بفضل الله
وغنيت (وحياة قلبي وأفراحه) يومها
دائما توقفني جملة:“ستحصل على أشياء ناقصة
تكتمل برضاك ،
النقص حكمة ربانية وضعها
في كل شخخص فينا،
ليذكرنا أن الكمال لله وحده.
وطالما أن هذه إرادة ربانية إذا ما في حرج
علينا في كشف أسرارنا
العلة ما لازم نخبيها
لأن إحنا مش متهمين عن أنفسنا لنبرر
إبتلائاتنا في الحياة وندافع عن حالنا.
إنتي وإنتَ وهي وهو وكلكم
سواء كنت سكري أو
غير سكري ما أتخلي الخوف من حكي الناس يسيطر
عليك وخلي الإرادة دائما سلاح.